I'm so excited to be here I'm also
excited that you all woke up that's
amazing you should like seriously give
yourselves a round of applause that's
really incredible day three of the
conference okay I'm not gonna delay much
further all right let's get started with
an animated Guide to view three
reactivity and internals what happens in
the exact moment where you understand a
new idea can you think back to the last
time that you had that moment that
moment where something clicked for you
many people call it an aha moment or
they liken it to a light bulb turning on
because it feels a little bit like that
it feels like someone turned on a light
in a previously dark space in your mind
many people say it's one of the happiest
feelings they felt in their lives and
that makes sense because neurologically
speaking you feel a surge of dopamine in
concert with a serotonin response your
body literally rewards you for making a
new connection and activates adrenaline
to make you feel more awake and alert so
what does this have to do with
reactivity well consider that aha moment
in the moment that you understood one of
your tools or an application in your
journey to getting something done you
felt everything was at your fingertips
our jobs as developers is to provide the
tools necessary to get people to this
moment to make them feel like nothing is
in their way and then everything that a
UI provides is right there in front of
them but they have superpowers too
getting things done this is important
because without a focus on what we're
building and how well our tools manage
state we spend what we spend our time
creating can be confusing
awkward ideally we don't want to show
people everything at once but only the
information that they need and in order
to do that well we have to respond to
change what does that look like when
done well well responding to change with
fluidity can feel like everything that
you touch responds immediately and
elegantly and you know where everything
is going
and how to retrieve everything once it's
gone conversely when we build you eyes
poorly they can feel unintuitive I don't
know what's gonna happen at this hotel
it's like a horror movie is gonna take
place here or something and then yikes
okay or maybe we don't know how to
support the user and we tell them too
much but things that respond well feels
so good things are hidden from view
until we need them
you're not scanning over an environment
that has too much information for you
everything responds just in the moment
that you need it it feels very fluid so
all this is fine and good but how do we
make that happen as developers well this
is one of the reasons why view is such a
lovely framework to work with it
responds elegantly to changes in the UI
and gives us everything that we need to
make powerful interfaces without
anything getting in our way but how how
does it do all of these amazing things
while keeping the surface ache API so
seamless today we're gonna find out how
by diving into an animated guide to view
three I'm Sara Dresner I'm on the view
core team I'm VP of developer experience
at natla Phi which is neither Netflix or
Shopify as much as that's super
confusing for my parents if you're not
familiar with it's my favorite way to
deploy sites and apps a few people
talked about it earlier yesterday and
I'm gonna talk about it a little bit
today but I'm gonna walk through but I'm
gonna walk through a ton of stuff today
and I want you to know that all of the
demos for this talk were written in
JavaScript and all are an are all open
source some of them are using some of
the same premises we're going to talk
about today which makes it really meta
I'm going to show some disparate
concepts sort of in an FAQ format and
what I mean by that is that people ask
me questions about view 3 all the time
and so I'm gonna take some of the most
frequently asked questions and address
them to
and break them down into the most simple
simple parts that I can but one thing to
note is that everything that I'm going
to show you is interrelated they all
work in concert together to create a
single experience
okay let's dive in what is reactivity
the canonical example that everyone uses
it uses because it's a great one is an
Excel spreadsheet if I have these two
numbers and I create a sum I can create
the sum here if I adjust that first cell
to 3 I don't have to do anything to
adjust that final one right it just
updates accordingly that's awesome
that's a really good example of
reactivity but JavaScript doesn't really
work like this usually right what we
have is two and three and then we have
some is five if I reassign the value of
three and print out some again it's not
going to reassign right that's not how
Java Script works so how are we gonna do
that in view well if we wanted to do
this in JavaScript what we would have to
do to get it done is to detect when
there's a change in one of the values
we'd have to track the function that
changes it and then we'd have to trigger
that function that changes it so it can
update the final value so that's how we
would normally make things done so how
does view 3 do this let's dive in so
we're gonna get this done with proxies
and I made an animated explainer to kind
of show you at a high level what's going
on we start with an object we add a
handler and a proxy to the object in
this case it's the same but look we can
intercept the object with this proxy but
here's the cool part if we change the
first object the proxied object updates
accordingly without adjusting the
handler with reactivity we can respond
to changes instantly cool so that was
kind of quick and high level right let's
dive in a little bit further and in
order to explore this concept let's talk
about what proxies are and what they can
do in general a proxy is an object that
in cases another
object or function and allows you to
intercept it and at its base core this
is what that syntax looks like new proxy
target and handler so if we have
something like this our dinner is going
to be tacos because tacos are wonderful
and we have a handler and we have a get
method and we pass in the target and
prop if we use square bracket notation
we can return and get the value so if I
have something like this
cons proxy equals new proxy and then I
say proxy dot meal what do you think is
gonna happen we get our tacos which is
great because tacos are awesome but if
we want to intercept this value we can
actually do that quite easily we can
actually say console dot log intercepted
or whatever we want to do here and as
you can see we've we're printing out
that intersect intercepted and then the
tacos cool so what happens if we don't
return that square bracket notation of
target prop well we can totally do
something else we don't actually have to
return that we can return whatever we
want in this area so if I wanted to swap
out your dinner and you were expecting
tacos and I wanted to give you a burger
I could totally do that I could say we
swapped out your dinner and a return a
burger and that that's what it would
print out we swapped out your burger
burger and that's awful right in
JavaScript we call this a trap because
it's a trap who's gonna give me a burger
instead of a taco that's ridiculous I
don't want that to happen anyway so this
this kind of interception is called a
trap in JavaScript all right let's go
back to this first example here we were
returning with that square bracket
notation but there's another way that we
could return here and actually we're
going to use it and this is very this is
an intrinsic to proxies this is
something that only proxies allows you
to do we can say return reflects dot get
and spread in the arguments and one of
the arguments that you might see here
that we added was this receiver the
reason why we might use this instead of
the way that we were returned
earlier is that this reflects that
proxies offers us allows us to bind this
properly which is really nice for view
because that's what we need to do with
view in order to make everything work
properly we need to bind all of that
this this in JavaScript cool so now
let's talk through what we might need to
do in order to get that cool reactivity
that we were talking about before we
might need to track anything that's
gonna change any kind of changes that
are gonna happen to those properties we
want to track and that get method and so
if you're looking inside the view code
base and you find that track piece
that's what that is doing that's what we
call it is we're tracking any changes
which are called effects so we're gonna
change track any effects so the next
thing we're gonna do is we're gonna set
some values so we're also gonna again
use the receiver and we're gonna use
reflects but above that we're gonna use
trigger and what trigger is gonna do is
run the changes we're gonna run the
effects we're gonna run anything that
needed to be updated inside of that so
here what we're gonna do is do a simple
check we're not gonna run all of that if
we don't need to right if the old value
is the same as the new value we don't
want to do that work so we're just gonna
do a simple check is the old value the
same as the new value okay great if not
then we're gonna trigger this cool so
let's go back to that original statement
of what we need to do to change a value
in JavaScript we need to detect when
there's a change in one of the values we
don't have to do that anymore because
the because we're using proxies that's
happening automatically cool the next
thing is that we're going to track the
function that changes it and that is
called track in view three we're gonna
trigger the function so they can update
the final value that is called trigger
in view three and that function that
changes it is called effect I'm gonna
use that word a few times but if you
need to look and see any of these things
you can go find them in the code
that way so other view 3 reactivity
notes this in this version of view
reactivity is in a separate package
inside the view next repo and the view
next repo is now open to the public so
if you want to go check it out after
this talk or at any point in your lives
you can go right here and that's where
that packages and now you know what to
kind of look for to understand those
changes another thing to note is proxies
are es6 so they don't offer support back
into old versions of ie
they we previously used object defined
property and now for modern browsers
were allowed to use things like proxy
and reflect cool let's move on
how do Watchers work okay that's all
fine and good soap but how do the
proxies relate to the actual changes
that are happening in the Dom updates
how do we hook into them with Watchers
and if you're not familiar with Watchers
here's how they work anytime we change
this property we've got this counter at
zero but if we increase it or decrease
it you can see I'm watching that
property any time that property changes
I can console.log but I can also do tons
of other things it allows me to hook
into that change and before we dive into
all of these concepts there are a couple
pieces of JavaScript that you should
understand before we talk about those
there are a set of base concepts to
understand get it set anyway in order to
understand the inner workings let's talk
about set map and weak map all right set
asset is a series of only values similar
to an array where any particular value
can only be inserted once so what does
that mean so if I have a new set of taco
burger taco and I console.log my lunch
items here the output is just going to
be taco and burger I can't keep adding
more tacos sadly I can only get that
once a map is a series of keys and
values similar to an object but with
some main differences and there's a
bunch of differences but I'm going to
talk about the ones that are more most
pertinent to view three key value pairs
remember their explicit ordering they
perform better in Sydney
areas where there's frequent additions
and deletions like set you can only add
the key value pairs one time and it has
some really nice methods like size has
set clear and you can delete by the key
so just like set in map if I take a new
map and then I set my first lunch is
tacos my second lunch is hamburgers and
then I tried to add lunch one as tacos
again
it's just gonna throw that away right
where we've just got lunch one and lunch
two it doesn't add it again right great
a week map it's similar to a map but the
references are held weekly and what I
mean by that is if you delete something
the reference can be garbage collected
in a map it can't but that also means it
loses some things that map past so it
loses the implicit ordering it loses
those nice methods like has and size and
things like that so the difference here
with weak map is garbage literally
garbage but like more like a happy kind
of garbage because we're able to garbage
collected so this makes view much faster
and I'll show you why all right let's
talk about what happens with those
proxies for the Dom when you pass an
object into a view instance as data view
converts it into a proxy this proxy
enables view to perform dependency
tracking and change notification when
properties are accessed or modified
there are two levels of dependencies for
every component the first level uses map
and stores the dependency for each
property the second level uses set to
track the effects that will be run when
the values change after the first render
the component will have tracked a list
of dependencies the properties that it
accessed during the render conversely
the component becomes a subscriber to
each of these properties when a proxy
intercepts a set operation the property
will notify all of its subscribed
components to re-render view reactivity
efficiently tracks changes in our
application and for each one of these
components we place them in a weap weak
map so that we can delete them as needed
great so we went through a lot of proxy
things we went through a lot of
reactivity things it's pretty high-level
if you want to dig in any further view
mastery has a great course on this that
I highly suggest you check out it's
really really awesome you heard from
Greg yesterday it's really great ok on
to the next we talked about reactivity
and Watchers and how Watchers how they
all work with all of our properties but
how do the properties get to the Dom how
are these changes actually getting
reflected that's a good little proxy
joke yeah anyway in our interfaces so
now let's cover how does the virtual Dom
work you might have heard this phrase
before the virtual Dom or the V Dom it's
a concept that many JavaScript
frameworks use to create really
performant you eyes not just view so
let's dig in okay so here's the Dom we
make a copy in JavaScript called the
virtual Dom we do this because touching
the Dom with JavaScript is
computationally expensive well
performing updates in javascript is
cheap finding the required Dom nodes and
updating them with JavaScript is
expensive so we batch calls and change
the Dom all at once the virtual Dom is a
lightweight JavaScript objects reflected
are created by this render function it
takes three arguments the element and
object with data props attributes and
more and an array the array is where we
pass in the children which all have
these arguments too so here's the text
and the div and its child the UI the UL
and now in turn the children the U at
the L eyes and if we need to update the
list items we do so in JavaScript and
only then do we update the actual Dom
the virtual Dom allows us to make
performing updates to our UI cool
awesome I
so now that we've talked about the
virtual Dom you might say like but what
about things that are pre-rendered what
about things that are server-side
rendered what about things that are
already pre compiled and everything is
done once it hits the client so a
question I get about this is like wait
how does that virtual Dom work and all
of that reactivity work if you're just
delivering static content and what is
this hydration thing that I keep hearing
about so I get this question a lot when
I talk about next or grid 'some which
are awesome meta frameworks but before
we talk about hydration let's first
cover why it's necessary
so why Jam stack with a client-side
rendering solution the server delivers a
file without content until you fetch
everything in the browser compiles it
and if you're far away from the server
the latency for that request gets really
long with older server-side rendering
solution the server compiles and fetches
everything and builds the website and
delivers a fully populated HTML page
that's oh that's much faster but every
time you navigate to a new route the
server has to do it all over again
compile and fetch it all and deliver it
this process delays the load sometimes
by whole seconds recently an approach
called Jam stack has become popular
which addresses both issues we build the
whole site and deploy the content to
CDNs which means it's geo replicated
across the globe and we never go back to
a server on subsequent requests we call
it jam stuck and not static because it
extends beyond static we can make the
page dynamic with API calls or service
functions like Roman did and the user
can interact with it what's more because
there's no server involved there are
fewer attack vectors so Jam stack
approaches can improve performance and
security my favorite version of this is
using next in universal rendering mode
coupled with a generate command to pre
build all the pages
I love deploying it on nullified that's
why I asked them to work there
which also offers some serverless
functions to make things dynamic and the
pairing is just a really awesome
developer experience but of course as
we're working
within the confines of a conference new
things are coming out all the time so
this is no longer the way to do things
as of yesterday as we heard from
Sebastian we are now going to set the
target to static and we're going to use
next build and next export in order to
use their static version and that's two
point one two I think I'm looking at
Sebastian in the audience okay so okay
why do we do all of that we are not no
longer having a single point of origin
server where you you're however your
proximity to it is however vast the
connection is it doesn't need to make
subsequent requests and it's better
security because it doesn't have active
they don't have access to the server so
that gives us amazing performance and
better security that's pretty awesome so
how does it become interactive if it's
all statically rendered that's where
this hydration comes in it can speed up
performance to initially serve raw HTML
and CSS we can do this by server-side
rendering an app and delivering it
statically after it's been served view
needs to take over the elements that are
dynamic this is called hydration since
the markups been rendered we don't throw
that away and recreate it instead we
want to hydrate the DOM and make it
interactive here the button can now
respond to changes and we can add to the
cart hydration lets us deliver fast and
secure sites and still have a reactive
UI so basically it walks over that Dom
figures out what's different in terms of
what needs to be reactive and what's not
it doesn't throw the Dom away and it
creates reactive bits from those pieces
ok we learned a lot in a half an hour
all right we covered how reactivity
works how view 3 uses proxies how
Watchers work in view 3 how the virtual
Dom works in view 3 how and why next in
grid some use pre-rendered content and
how they then hydrate the Dom that's
fantastic it's very early in the morning
and you all made it here that's
all grades now we know so many things
and our boundaries are endless and if
you ever need access to these materials
to review I've collected all the
materials here they're all open source
you can dive into the code for how I
built them and you can explore them and
soon they'll all be part of our new
reactivity section coming in the
upcoming revised view Docs as well and
not only can you make beautiful
performance experiences on the web you
know how reactive premises and concepts
are keeping your users focused on tasks
and enabling them to have superpowers
while they traverse your applications
thank you
[Applause]